president Trump pursues positive
policies but his wild statements kept
the headlines Joe Biden banks on being
boring
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show we have a lot to get to today the
news cycle seems to be getting more
fragmentary and more wild so that means
lots of fun for us so we will jump in in
just one moment first these days
workplaces offer some pretty nice perks
to their employees like for example the
folks who work at our company they get
to work like 18-hour days that get to go
home for four hours come back in the
morning and do this show also they get
some life insurance but maybe the life
insurance at your workplace isn't up to
snuff
or maybe it's pretty good but you need
more life insurance well this is where
policy genius comes in policy genius is
the easy way to shop for life insurance
online in ten minutes you can compare
quotes from top insurers and find the
right amounts of coverage at the best
possible price if you've got workplace
life insurance the policy genius team
can review that policy and let you know
what additional coverage you might need
workplace life insurance policies
they're like workplace snacks they're
better than nothing but they are not
quite enough head on over to policy
genius calm today find out how to
supplement your workplace life insurance
and better protect your family this is
also the good adult thing to do I know
no one likes to think about death which
means nobody likes to think about life
insurance so why spend tons of time
thinking about it just get it taken care
of
and that way if you plotz your family is
taken care of and you didn't spend half
your life looking for life insurance go
check them out at policy genius.com they
are really good at what they do they
will help you out policy genius.com
today find out how to supplement that
workplace life insurance and better
protect your family ok so as always
President Trump is an exercise in
contradiction this is a man who contains
multitudes multitudes so we've been
using this model since all the way back
in 2015 and it is called the good trump
bad Trump model in fact we even had a
theme song for a good trump bad Trump
and I think is it time guys should we
bring back the Trump bad Trump I think
the time has come a little bit of our
theme song please
[Music]
and now because the President of the
United States means that the news cycle
is approximately 32 seconds long we get
plenty of both on any given day now we
used to have these little stick figure
heads and I would put up the happy face
for Trump and I'd put up the sad face
for Trump but I didn't tell my producers
to get that together so that's not their
fault that one is on me and we had a
super late night in any case we begin
with good Trump because nobody is
talking about the good Trump the good
Trump as usual is when it comes to
policy so as I have said since President
Trump was elected he has wildly
surpassed my expectations in terms of
policy and the president actually has
done some good policy things over the
last 48 72 hours now all of that has
been obscured as we will see by bad
Trump because people pay a lot more
attention to bad Trump then good Trump
because bad Trump is a lot louder it's
just like your kids right when your kids
are good you don't really notice them
when your kids are good yeah they're
doing their homework and they're reading
books in their room and they're not
slamming their fingers into doors you
know when they're doing that you don't
really notice them too much but then
when they're bad then you really notice
them a lot well the same thing is true
of President so let's talk about some of
the good stuff that President Trump has
been doing so finally at long last the
Trump administration on Wednesday
unveiled the regulation to allow it to
indefinitely detain migrant families who
illegally cross the border now I am NOT
saying it is wonderful to detain people
who cross the border I am saying it is
wonderful that we are changing the rules
that created the necessity for family
separation so basically the choice that
was provided under law to the Trump
administration thanks to the so-called
Flores settlement in 1997 as amended by
Obama administration regulations in 2015
the rules stated that if somebody came
across the border with a family member
with a with a young child the child
could not be kept in custody with the
parents for more than 20 days which
meant that you would have to separate
the child from the parents if you wished
to arrest the parents or you would have
to catch and release everybody and this
is why you have seen a dramatic
skyrocketing number of families crossing
the border because if you're a parent
and you want to be released into the
general population you should bring your
child that's the best way to do it let's
say you got a cousin here you bring your
kid you figure okay my kid will stay
with my cousin and then after like two
weeks they will probably release me so
that I can be with Mike
because they don't want the bad optics
of separating children from parents well
the Trump administration was dealing
with that by saying we're going to
arrest everybody and a family
separations occur well guess what them's
the wages of being arrested everybody
else in the United States when they get
arrested they are separated from their
kids no different when it comes to
illegal immigration and people illegally
trying to claim for example asylum
without being properly processed or
trying to claim asylum when they are not
actually eligible for asylum well there
was something the Trump administration
could always have done it was under
consideration for no good reason it was
delayed by the Department of Homeland
Security now the Trump administration
has come forward with a policy and the
policy basically says they're going to
create humane living conditions which
isn't as you need it right mean that is
good we want kids kept inhumane living
conditions with their families
that would be the goal and they can do
this by a shift in regulation the rule
replaces a decades-old court agreement
that mandates a level of care for
migrant children and limits how long the
government can hold them in custody for
more than a year the White House has
pressed the Department of Homeland
Security to find a way to eliminate the
agreement known as the Flores settlement
which limits the time children can spend
in detention and establishes minimum
standards for holding facilities for
families and children according to the
New York Times immigration hardliners
and said inside the administration say
the move is crucial to halting the flow
of migrants across the southwestern
border which makes perfect sense if it
were not true that this were
incentivizing families to cross the
border you would have not seen a
skyrocketing number of families crossing
the border it would've been the same
general population of illegal immigrants
coming before largely non-married men
right that's who was crossing the border
for a very long time in the United
States and then suddenly in the last few
years after the Obama administration put
in place its regulatory response to
Flores the nature of the immigration
shifted and even the mainstream media
were acknowledging that they were seeing
a wild and crazy'
upswing in the number of families
crossing the border why because when you
change the incentive structure people's
behavior changes the administration's
goal with the new rule is deterrence and
it's message to families fleeing Central
America is blunt come here and we will
lock you up critics say it is the latest
in a series of policies by President
Trump meant to close off the United
States from the rest of the world no
this is the latest in a series of
policies by President Trump to enforce
our immigration laws if you cross the
border you
to be held in detention until you are
processed and we should provide the
proper methods to keep you in humane
conditions we should provide the proper
resources to the court so that we can
process you quickly and we can deport
you if you need deportation and so that
you can be admitted if you deserve
asylum this entire process should be
wildly expedited and resources must be
devoted to the border along these
grounds President Trump said on
Wednesday one of the things that will
happen when they realize the borders are
closing the wall is being built we are
building tremendous numbers of miles of
wall right now in different locations it
all comes together make a beautiful Beza
boom they make a thousand-piece
beautiful huzza
of a rhinoceros speaking to reporters at
the White House President Trump asserted
the new rule would make it almost
impossible for people to come into our
country illegally well it would
certainly make it more difficult for
people to be released into the country
illegally the catch and release programs
that the Democrats have been pushing for
basically allow people to be released
into the country they show up for their
first court hearing and then a second
court hearing is set if they are not
processed within a certain amount of
time they actually get into automatic
visa and then people just overstay the
visa and that's how you end up with
folks in the United States for 10-15
years
overstaying a visa that they received
because the system was too slow the new
regulation does require approval from a
federal judge as well administration
officials said they expected it to be
immediately challenged in court once in
effect it would specifically abolish a
20-day limit on detaining families and
immigration jails a cap that President
Trump has repeatedly complained has led
to the catch and release of families
which of course is also true also as I
say the other half of this regulation
which is good and necessary as it
establishes minimum necessities at
detention centers because we don't need
more stories of detaining children being
kept under aluminum foil wrapping and
people who come here should be treated
humanely many of those people are going
to end up becoming American citizens
even if they weren't they should be
treated humanely obviously Kevin McLean
and said what this will do is
substantially increase our ability to
end the catch and release challenges
that have fueled the crisis he's the
acting Secretary of Homeland Security he
said the regulation restores integrity
to our immigration system would provide
high standards for the care of children
naturally people at the ACLU are calling
this an attack on children so just to
get this straight the ACLU believes it's
in
tack-on children to separate them from
their parents but it's also an attack on
children do not separate them from their
parents so the only solution according
to the ACLU is in fact catch and release
combine catch and release with the
Democrats proposal to get rid of
criminal penalties for crossing the
border illegally and combine that in
turn with the stated Democratic position
by most of the major presidential
candidates that they would not support
anyone in the United States illegally
who does not have a separate crime on
record except for illegal immigration
and suddenly you're talking a full on
open borders regime I mean that is what
the ACLU and so many folks on the Left
are talking about well they'd say we're
not Pro open borders then they're going
to have to explain how they can
simultaneously hold that
catch-and-release should be the
generalized policy that there should be
no criminality attached to illegally
crossing the border and that nobody
should be nobody should be deported
except if they commit a crime that is
not illegally crossing the border that
is an open borders policy there is no
other way to put it that's not just me
saying it former homeland security
secretary under Barack Obama jeh Johnson
said the same thing so this is a good
piece of policy from the Trump
administration and it's not getting a
lot of coverage specifically because it
does cut against a lot of the media's
narrative when it comes to illegal
immigration and the New York Times
obviously is covering it but you haven't
seen it too much on CNN or MSNBC why
because these regulations do include
provisions about treating everybody
humanely so we'll have to see how the
regulations are drawn but if they do
what they are supposed to do here this
is a good piece of policy by the Trump
administration another good piece of
policy by the Trump administration so
the Trump administration has now
promulgated regulations surrounding
title 10 funding and those regulations
surrounding title 10 funding say that if
we give you money for a family planning
program that it can't be used for
abortion and that means that you have to
have a separate facility where you are
not providing abortions and we will fund
those we're not going to provide the
facilities where the abortions are
happening and we are not going to allow
you to use the money fungible this has
been one of the major critiques of title
10 by conservatives it is correct if you
sign a giant check to Planned Parenthood
and say we want you to use this for
birth control and then Planned
Parenthood says we'll use it for birth
control and then they just use it to
paint their building or they use it to
pay their secretaries the
they're actually using the money to pay
expenses that alleviate the the cost of
providing abortions the taxpayer funding
is in fact being used to pay abortions I
mean the argument is basically that if
you and your wife have a joint bank
account and you put all your money in
the joint bank account and your wife
goes shopping you are paying for her
shopping right obviously this is true
and vice-versa if your wife is the one
who's the man the main breadwinner in
your house okay well if you are putting
money into a slush fund for Planned
Parenthood and Planned Parenthood is
performing lots of abortions you are
funding Planned Parenthood's abortions
well the title 10 rules just changed the
federal government cannot legally pay
for most abortions according to the
Atlantic but it does give money to
abortion providers like Planned
Parenthood for all sorts of other
reproductive health services especially
for low-income women for years
conservatives have been arguing that
money is fungible and if you cut a check
to Planned Parenthood it will be used
for abortion that's why the Trump
administration took took aim at title 10
a decade's old family planning program
that provides money for low-income women
to access birth control cancer and STD
screenings breast exams and more under
the new rule title ten recipients are no
longer allowed to provide women with
information about where and how they can
get an abortion and they cannot
encourage women to seek out the
procedure so if a woman comes in and she
says I want an abortion they're not
allowed to say well great idea you
should have one right there they're not
allowed to encourage abortion and that's
what Planned Parenthood has been doing
Planned Parenthood routinely encourages
abortion as opposed to providing a
fulsome view of the choices available to
a woman legally that's why Planned
Parenthood has long opposed demanded the
mandatory use of ultrasound before an
abortion takes place because it turns
out that once women tend to see the
living baby inside of them they're much
less apt to kill the living baby inside
of them a frequently asked question on
the HHS website says that the rule
permits but does not require
non-directive counseling on abortion
meaning that it doesn't say you have to
tell women where they can get an
abortion but it allows you to counsel on
abortion it allows doctors to provide
patients with complete factual
information about all medical options
but title 10 recipients may not
encourage a patient to seek an abortion
it does not reduce family planning a
family planning funding by a single
dollar it's just that basically plan
parenthood is now withdrawn from title
ten funding because they say we're not
going to open a separate facility we are
not going to not direct people to have
abortions so we just want to take the 60
million dollars of federal funding and
it was normally coming our way on the
HHS website the administration directly
calls out Planned Parenthood which
claims to serve 40 percent of all title
ten recipients in the country the
website says to the extent that Planned
Parenthood claims and it must make
burdensome changes to comply with the
final rule and is actually choosing to
place a higher priority on the ability
to refer for abortion instead of
continuing to receive federal funds this
is exactly right this is exactly right
Planned Parenthood cares more about
pushing abortion than they do about all
other forms of reproductive women's
health otherwise they could just split
off an organization that doesn't do
abortion but they're not going to do
that because they are an abortion mill
they've always been an abortion mill so
good for the Trump administration for
pushing that policy forward okay so that
is the good Trump in a second we are
going to get to be bad Trump because
unfortunately the bad Trump gets a lot
more press then the good Trump we'll get
to that in just one second first
president Trump has in fact as I've been
talking about kept a lot of his promises
right now he's effectively succeeded in
defunding Planned Parenthood he's
obviously trying to do his best in
enforcing our immigration laws he has
passed a massive tax cut he's moved the
embassy to Jerusalem the president sent
a lot of really good things on policy
he's running his reelection campaign at
least in part on this record I wish for
running his whole reelection campaign on
that record but he's still chasing after
one of his goals which is to bring down
the cost of prescription drug prices a
lot of folks on the Left the press yes
even some big governments are making
that kind of hard for President Trump to
actually bring down those prices the
result is that amazingly some people in
the Trump administration in the name of
claiming victory once we adopt some of
the left's socialistic top-down price
control plans which is not a good idea
help Freedom Works stop Senate Democrats
from capping your care go to don't cap
my CARICOM and sign the petition a lot
of people have been talking price
controls on drugs through Medicare
there's a problem with this price
controls that generally lead to less
innovation and less investments that's
exactly the stuff that you need the R&D
that is going to develop all of the new
treatments and methods of care that are
necessary in medicine America is
responsible for over half of the world's
medical innovation it's imperative that
that continue head on over to don't cap
my CARICOM right now help freedom work
stop the Senate from capping or Cara
sign that petition
right now again that's don't cap my
CARICOM right now and help Freedom Works
stop the Senate from capping your care
don't cap my care.com okay so now
unfortunately it is time to get to bad
Trump so they're a bunch of minor stores
I don't know why President Trump feels
the necessity to speak out on every
issue as I have said repeatedly for
years at this point
I've proposed a couple of strategies for
president Trump to win reelection
strategy number one is that the White
House creates an alternative Twitter app
and they voted on the president's phone
and the president tweets into the
Twitter app and it just spits back
automated messages magnet you're the
best we love you
hashtag mega and then jiff Trump on a
tank right oh and then Trump just sits
there and he's super happy all the time
he goes about his business we got all
the good policies that we're talking
about and nobody ever hears about the
stuff that he's tweeting into the
Twitter machines that that's solution
number one solution number two is that
we stock the upstairs of the White House
with with maybe a bunch of reruns of
shark week maybe a porn star or two and
then he just hangs out there for a
couple of years and he doesn't talk very
much in public and then he's president
forever basically but the president
because when he is frustrated he tends
to lash out and he is frustrated at the
media and by the way his frustration
with the media is justified I'm not
saying that he shouldn't be frustrated
with the media he certainly should be
frustrated with the media they're
garbage at their jobs we'll get to that
in a minute but Trump does not help
himself when he creates a feeling of
chaos in a time when there should not be
great feelings of chaos we do not have a
chaotic foreign policy situation on the
horizon right now we do not have a
chaotic domestic economic situation
right now and yet there is this palpable
feeling of chaos and it is forwarded by
President Trump fueling the necessity
every five minutes to sound off on
whatever random thing he sees on the
news that day listen I love talk radio
I'm on talk radio right I enjoy talk
radio but we don't need president Donny
from Queens you're on line one we need
President Trump to feel like a steady
presence in American life somebody who's
steady and solidifying do you feel that
I think a lot of women in the suburbs
don't feel that I think the polling is
showing that well yesterday President
Trump decided it was time to sound off
on a variety of random topics
he decided that who's going to attack
Ford Motor Company why what was the
point of this well apparently he's angry
at Ford Motor Company
because foud more afford more has back
to deal with California for stricter
fuel economy standards now I don't blame
Ford for that they the state of
California is creating its own state
efficiency standards with regard to cars
that can drive in California and her
license to drive in California and this
means that Ford is figuring okay well it
is cheaper for us to produce those cars
because California's a huge market
cheaper for us to produce a lot more
fuel-efficient cars that can pass all of
the standards and then to produce less
fuel-efficient cars and then have to
create special fuel-efficient cars just
for California well Trump got really mad
at this and he started tweeting out
about it I don't know why no idea why
well is there a point to this from tweet
out Henry Ford would be very
disappointed if he saw his modern-day
descendants running to build a much more
expensive car that is far less safe and
does it work as well because execs don't
want to fight
California regulators car companies
should know that when this
administration's alternative is no
longer available
California will squeeze them to a point
of business ruin only reason California
is now talking to them is because the
feds are giving a far better alternative
which is much better for consumers and
now I may not like California's fuel
efficiency standards but I understand
why Ford Motor Company is saying to
itself we can't rely on President Trump
loosening fuel efficiency standards for
the next 18 months to build out our
entire business line as possible he
won't be president in 18 months it is
also quite possible that even if he is
president in 18 months he has a
Democratic Congress or he changes his
mind on fuel efficiency whatever the
whatever the truth is on this the
chances that fuel efficiency standards
are going to remain low in the United
States are extremely low so if you're
the businessperson over at Ford you know
this is not a political thing this is a
business thing if you're the business
person over at Ford you have to put in
place the technologies to develop new
cars why would you follow the
temporarily loosened standards and fight
the state of California when you
understand that the long range goals of
the government more generally speaking
are to crack down on your industry and
make fuel efficiency higher rather than
lower Ford is one of 4 automakers along
with Honda
and Volkswagen that reached a voluntary
agreement with California on fuel
efficiency rules defying president Trump
in his administration's effort to strip
the state of the right to fight climate
change by setting its own standards the
rules under the California plan are
looser than the Obama era regulations
but stricter than what Trump is proposed
and again this is because if you're a
business you're going to hedge your bets
when government is this big you had your
bets Trump said that the company founder
Henry Ford would be very disappointed
Ford said in a statement it is focused
on acting to protect the environment
while also protecting the affordability
of vehicles obviously there are a lot of
new consumers who actually are sort of
concerned about carbon emissions and
they're looking for fuel efficiency as
well turns out it is cheaper many times
to get a fuel-efficient car over the
course of time they said this agreement
with California provides regulatory
stability while reducing carbon
emissions more than complying with two
different standards right that is what I
am saying right that the business case
is why would we have a standard for
California and a standard for the rest
of the country and design our factories
to comply with both standards as opposed
to having one uniform standard there's
no evidence that existing fuel economy
rules with degrade vehicle performance
as president Trump suggests it is true
that the cars will be lighter I mean
that is sort of how this works you want
a more fuel-efficient vehicle the car
can't be quite as heavy but as we move
to lighter cars on the road pretty much
all the cars on the rotor lighter this
is why if you have a car from 1970 it
looks like a tank right now whatever the
case may be is it beneficial for the
president to be tweeting out about Henry
Ford and creating a news cycle in which
he's at war with one of America's iconic
motor companies this is a great idea in
the run-up to an election where he needs
to win like Michigan is that is that a
smart move well if you like that one I
got another one for you the president's
going to war with Denmark so that's
exciting you know I know that when I
woke up a couple of days ago I thought
to myself you know what those those
Danes we got to do something about
Greenland man Greenland the future of
America lies on glaciers now listen I'm
fine with I'm all for buying Greenland
you know bike and frankly I don't think
it's a big deal that president from
wanted to buy Greenland the fact is that
the United States bought the US Virgin
Islands from Denmark they were called
the Dutch West Indies until we bought
them and turned them into the US Virgin
Islands solid real estate deal the
president has decided that it
is imperative that we get into a
diplomatic spat when Greenland says it's
not for sale
we're now gonna have an international
issue over whether we buy a giant island
that has 56,000 people on it what are we
gonna do like relocate populations
they're like what what are what are we
what are we talking about doing with
Greenland that makes it so all-fired
important that we're now canceling state
visits to Denmark so president Trump is
now in a personal spat with the prime
minister of Denmark which is just that
that's what we needed right I mean I
just talked about all the good policy
Trump is pursuing but certainly what
makes the American people feel more safe
and secure and solid is when the
president is in a pissing match with the
prime minister of Denmark because of all
the cruel inhumane States on planet
earth that we need to face down and look
directly in the eye Denmark man those
Danes can't be trusted not in the
slightest kim jungeun best friends prime
minister of Denmark screw that person
president Trump on Wednesday lashed out
at the Danish Prime Minister met
Fredrickson saying the leader of the US
ally had made nasty comments about his
interest in having the United States
purchase Greenland Trump announced on
Tuesday night he was calling off a plan
two day visit to Copenhagen early next
month over Fredrickson's refusal to
entertain the sale of Greenland
apparently Trump tweeted this out he
said I thought it was not a nice
statement the way she blew me off
she shouldn't treat the United States
that way she said absurd that's not the
right way that's not the right word to
use President Trump is an expert in the
use of words he has all of the best
words is this worthwhile I did honestly
is it worthwhile hey I understand he's
gonna be Trump we all get it at this
point but if that a good thing for his
re-election prospects just generally is
it necessary in a second they'll talk a
little bit more about the the bad Trump
aspect of banter and then we'll get to
the media treatment which of course is
bizarre and insane and should be an
entire line of attack for president
Trump going into 2020 I'll get to that
in just a second first I love my helix
sleep mattress in fact I love it so much
that I was late for my show this morning
I mean the fact is that helix mattresses
are top-notch they're so good that I got
one for my sister and her husband upon
the occasion of their May
that was our wedding gift to them
because they are awesome they are
personalized to you hulex leap has a
quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you no matter how you sleep
on your side on your back hot sleeper
whatever helix can make what your body
needs just go to helix sleep calm slash
men take their two-minute sleep please
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life for couples hulex can
even split that mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they've
got a 10 year warranty you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix is offering
up to 125 bucks off all mattress orders
for our listeners get up to 125 bucks
off at helix sleep calm slash fan which
is a spectacular deal again my wife and
I took a two-minute sleep quiz and it's
great it's fantastic
that's helix sleep calm slash Ben helix
sleep calm slash man for up to 125 bucks
off your mattress order helix sleep calm
slash Ben go check it out right now okay
so as I say two things I do not think
needed to be at the top of the headlines
so I've given you two big headlines for
Trump would actually promulgating
regulations that will cut down on
illegal immigration and also will allow
children to stay with their parents
after two years of controversy over that
that's a big thing think number two
that's a big thing Planned Parenthood
defunding big promise kept shouldn't
those be the things we're talking about
today well instead we're talking about
Trump versus Ford and Trump vs. Denmark
over Greenland Chris Matthews aquarium
set over this place is unbelievable
president Trump tell you what Denmark
coming here in the morning come here
they show a crazy-looking I mean why are
you getting angry at the Danes wait so
angry man I love Hans Christian Andersen
deal when you live in a shoe all sorts
of fairy tales I love I'll tell you what
I love most of all I love coming in here
half drunk and talking about president
trunk and Bugsy Siegel and making
gangster references go
president Trump is picking a fight with
a loyal American ally for no apparent
reason he's cancelled a state visit to
Denmark insulted its Prime Minister and
thrown an historic relationship into
chaos Denmark is a good country its
pro-american as hell is that now I like
we dream the world would be a now of any
country like our country and now this
guy like bugs
Seagal walks by it like in the movie
Warren Beatty played the guy goes PI
outside like that house cuz in the house
and says I want to buy your house is
like Warren Beatty love it
Warren Beatty terrible one baby's great
in shampoo was this great inbreds
I liked the message in the movie read
very pro-communist I didn't like really
warm based performance but this is just
like Bugsy Siegel that's a movie nobody
saw right he's supposed to be really
good wasn't that good Warren Beatty's
kind of overrated
kind of liked him in bulwark whenever
that movie was remember that Chris
Matthews ever so we say sorry once I
getting into the Christmas it's very
difficult to get out of the Chris
Matthews in any case you can see what
the media are in it for right the media
would love a feeling of chaos this is
the Democratic campaign 2020 Democratic
campaign strategy 2020 Trump's crazy
that's the campaign that's the whole
campaign and Democrats are totally into
it
and when President Trump gets angry
about that he's not totally wrong right
so president Trump yesterday was talking
about the economy and there are in fact
some economic reports that are not good
for the president there was a report
that came out yesterday that said that
the United States created half a million
fewer jobs since 2018 and previously
reported according to new figures so we
dramatically overestimated the number of
jobs that were created as of 2018 and
early 2019 the newly revised figures
according to Market Watch indicate the
economy didn't get a huge boost last
year from the Trump tax cuts and higher
federal spending
they also signaled that the economy is a
bit weaker than previously believed and
could give the Federal Reserve even
greater reason to cut interest rates in
September I mean really what it
indicates considering that wages have
been going up is that we may have maxed
out the employment market just generally
we didn't create all that many new jobs
because innovation remains kind of low
but the jobs that are there there are a
lot of people who the employers are
looking for people to fill those jobs
with that said the revised numbers
downward are really not good for Trump
it's the biggest revision downward since
2009 the annual benchmark revision is
much larger about three times larger
than is typically the case so President
Trump is facing that headwind it is also
true that Trump is struggling to figure
out exactly how to combat the
possibility of an economic slowdown he
says there will be no more payroll tax
so that had been floated by the White
House than done floated by the White
House then floated by the White House
again apparently he said the nation
already had a strong economy Trump's
been sending mixed signals on all of
this also the deficit continues to soar
President Trump has fought all of this
by blaming the Federal Reserve and so
President Trump says you know the
Federal Reserve is to blame we need to
lower the the interest rates again this
is not a message of solidity you want a
message that everything's fine
right that is them because everything is
basically fine right but instead
President Trump is out there saying
everything is fine also the Federal
Reserve should act like this is a crisis
and cut the and cut the interest rates
by a hundred basis points which is
basically an emergency sighs Fed rate
cut here's President Trump yesterday he
raised interest rates too fast too
furious and we have a normalized great
eyeball at that and now we have to go
the other direction we'll see if he
doesn't if he does it you'll see a
rocket ship you'll see a film if he
doesn't we have a very strong economy
the Federal Reserve has let us down they
missed the call they raised him too fast
they raised a dua and they didn't want
the date of tightening they shouldn't
have done the tightening and they
shouldn't have raised it to the extent
we could have had some raises but
nothing like they did to fast to furious
I witnessed a Hobson shot over the
weekend it was unbelievable
those paper the rack unbelievable it but
Trump is not wrong that Democrats are
talking down the economy he's not wrong
that the media and Democrats are looking
for a dual narrative one the economy is
not as strong to that Trump is a wild
man right those those are the dual
narratives that the Democrats are
pushing Trump said Democrats are talking
down the economy he is correct the big
news of which many of you are members
is trying to convince the public to have
a recession let's have a recession the
United States is doing phenomenally well
but one thing I have to do is
economically take on China because China
has been ripping us off for many years
President Clinton President Bush and
President Obama and others should have
done this long before me
okay so Mia Trump is not wrong that
they're talking down they cut by the way
the media are treating it like a great
revelation when a president suggests
that his political opposition is talking
down the economy Barak Obama said the
same thing in 2012 he said that
Republicans were talking down the
economy when we were in the middle of
this very very weak recovery I'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about why it is not worthwhile to visit
the post office the post office has lots
of great services they do a lot of
wonderful things for you but one thing
about the post office that kind of sucks
is that you have to go there
right you have to go there get to wait
in line it takes more time last time I
went to the post office I got a giant
ticket because Los Angeles is governed
like the garbage city that has turned
into it's a city where if I were to sit
outside the post office shooting heroin
into my veins and crapping on the
sidewalk the cops would do nothing but
if I park outside in the red zone for
more than five minutes then I get 120
dollar ticket that's what happened last
time I was at the post office not me
crapping on the sidewalk and doing
heroin me getting a parking ticket
well I'm no longer going to the post
office instead I use stamps calm
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready you just hand it to your
mail carrier or drop it in a mailbox it
is indeed that simple with Sam's comm
you get five cents off every first class
stamp up to 40% off Priority Mail not to
mention it is a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters stamps
calm it's a no-brainer it saves you time
it saves you money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps come right
now our listeners get a special offer to
includes a four week trial plus free
postage digital scale no long term
commitment hella video just go to stamps
calm click that microphone at the top of
the homepage type in Shapiro that stamps
comm enter Shapiro in just a sec
we're going to get to why Trump is
correct the Democrats are talking down
the economy why that's not a new
narrative from a president and then
we'll get to how the media are really
pushing hard for the Democratic
narrative you know my friend
Andrew Breitbart used to call it the
Democrat media complex that's what it is
that's what it is no questions no doubt
well gets that in one second first the
daily wire has turned four years old we
are thrilled about this because if it
did not we would not be here talking to
you right now so you should be thrilled
too as a thank you to our fans have made
that possible we are giving away one
month of our premium a monthly
subscription to anyone who uses this
code it's secret you ready birthday
that's right for all of August as we
celebrate this milestone we are giving
away a free first month for new premiums
monthly subscribers again just use that
magic code birthday and come join the
fun make the magic happen also go
subscribe over at daily wire.com when
you do you got this the very greatest in
all beverage vessels the leftist Cheers
hot or cold tumblr unbelievable if
you've never seen a life-sized leftist
tears hot recalled tumblr and when I say
life says I mean like the size of a
human being you should have come to our
event last night where one of our
producers was forced by us to Don the
costume of a leftist years Hydra called
tumblr and go to war with a louder with
crowd or life-sized mug it was amusing
to us but not to the audience it cost a
fortune but it amused us so at least at
least we fulfilled that purpose and
that's where your hard-earned subscriber
dollars are talking to putting our
producers in leg size tumblers I know it
sounds like just a party over here right
it isn't it let me just tell you we all
worked 18-hour days yesterday and now
we're back here with you again if you
want to keep us bringing you the show
please subscribe we really appreciate it
we had the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
okay so when President Trump says the
Democrats are talking down the economy
he is eminently correct obviously this
is true you know who else says he's
right John Delaney Democratic
presidential candidate and the only sane
person left in the Democratic field
here's John's lady saying yeah Democrats
are cheering on a recession it feels
like some Democrats are cheering on a
recession because they want to stick it
to the Trump I don't want a recession
because I don't want these workers in
here to face a recession but I worry
that Trump's policies are bringing one
on now the media keeps saying about
Trump we're not we're not talking down
the economy how dare he that's
unprecedented yeah sure Barack Obama
circa 2012 saying the exact same thing
every president suggests that if the
economy is weakening that it's the
opposition talking down the economy
debate going on around the budget in the
coming months Republicans in Congress
are sadly trying to cut some of the
investments that could spur additional
growth that's the debate that is worthy
of the American people not fantasy
name-calling not trying to talk down to
the American economy what we have done
has made a difference and that there's a
huge gap between the rhetoric that's
going on out there
and the reality of success because
Obama's doing exactly the same thing
circa 2012 The Donald Trump is doing
today but very very bad when Donald
Trump does it according to the media and
this brings us to the media again the
dual narrative that is now being
promoted by the media by and large falls
into two categories one the economy is
going to crash it's going to burn we're
all going to die all right okay now
there are real signs of a recession that
may happen in the next two years
sometime but right now the fundamentals
of the American economy remain pretty
strong despite the downgrading of growth
rates from last year and the fact is
that probably sometime in the next four
years there will be a recession because
every 10 to 12 years in the United
States we have a recession we had one in
2000 we had one in 2007-2008 we had one
in 1991 we had one in 1987 we had one in
1980 right so the recessions are fairly
common in American life it's been a
while since we've had one I technically
speaking it has been since
2009 since we have had a recession we're
all the way in 2019 so you would expect
at some time in the next few years there
will be a recession but the the notion
that we are on the verge of it because
of Trump or something like that is just
silly but that's what the media are
pushing at this point and pushing that
narrative and they're pushing the Trump
is wildman narrative and so when Trump
gets angry at the media he's not wrong
now pushing the Trump is wildman
narrative the New York Times has an
editorial today and this is so rich it
is beyond believing the New York Times
has an editorial today called mr. Trump
stop questioning the loyalty of American
Jews this have calls of course follows
on the heels of president from
suggesting that Jews who vote Democrat
are disloyal and as I explained
yesterday there are a couple of ways to
read that than a real problem and then
there's one way to read it that really
is not a problem and the way to read it
that's not a problem is that Judaism is
a philosophy and a religion and that
that philosophy and religion has certain
tenets that do not match up with the
Democratic Party I've said that myself I
will continue to say that myself because
it happens to be 100% true nonetheless
the New York Times suggesting that Trump
is the great anti-semite the New York
Times has spent the last several months
defending at peril of its own
credibility receded to leave in ohan
Omar when Ilhan Omar's had openly
anti-semitic things the headline from
the New York Times was Ilhan Omar's
criticism raises the question is AIPAC
too powerful so just to get this
straight they're accusing Trump of
engaging in dual loyalty smears in order
to harm Jews because he's a brutal
vicious anti-semite who happens to be
the most pro-israel president in
American history and also receded to
Leoben Ilhan Omar wonderful hey this is
gaslighting of the highest order
if you want to boil down the last 48
hours of from controversy it goes on the
Jewish thing it goes something like this
Johanna Maher and Rashida to leave our
openly anti-semitic the media go are
those awful Jews in Israel being so mean
to receipt it to Leoben ohon Omar Trump
going I can't believe the Jews would
vote for the party that supports receded
to leave in no Hanauma and me to go and
look at that anti-semitism right that's
the narrative over the last so spare me
New York Times spare me
and by the way spare me all of your talk
about purity when it comes to your when
it comes to your own publication
Breitbart has a big report today about a
New York Times political editor with
years long history of anti-semitic and
racist comments on his Twitter page his
name is Tom Wright Pierce aunty he's
been a senior staff editor at The New
York Times for more than 5 years
according to his LinkedIn page and his
Twitter page oversees the newspapers
political coverage they're a bunch of
tweets that he has sent out over the
years in 2010 he sent one out that said
I was going to say crappy Jew year but
one of my resolutions is to be less
anti-semitic so happy Jew year you Jews
sounds like a delight hey he also in
2009 tweeted out a picture of a kebab
vehicle that has a menorah on top of it
and he said who called the Jew police
and so it sounds like a wonderful dude
now I will note here I don't think that
he should be fired because I have a
basic rule when it comes to American
life digging up old crap on people and
then using it to destroy their careers
as a leftist tactic it is a leftist
tactic because it doesn't tell you much
about what they believe today you can't
go back in a time machine and change it
and delete it I said it's about Ralph
Northam I said this about Sarah Zhang
I've said it on the right side of the
aisle about a bevy of figures I don't
think that it's a good tactic however
the New York Times standard is not my
standard their standard is that anybody
should be able to be destroyed based on
older material so as a matter of
mutually assured destruction I don't
think that it's inappropriate for the
right to point this out I would also say
that the New York Times I'm gonna take
it with a large grain of salt when they
start sounding off about anti-semitism
Anderson Cooper was doing the same thing
last night again pushing the narrative
that everything's crazy inside the
administration and Trump's an
anti-semite and it's all too wild here
was the Anderson Cooper blowing up at
president Trump and Ivanka Trump in a
way he never would have blown up it
receded to leave in Ojai Nomar and in
fact did not nevertheless the theme of
disloyal American Jews from this
president continues Ivanka Trump must be
very proud of her dad tonight and could
probably just watch for an Ivanka leak
in the coming days about how she tried
to talk her father you know to change
that kind of language it's a classic
Ivanka move the president also today
executed a move rarely seen in modern
day politics he denied something that he
confirmed yesterday which was then
denying what the White House had been
denying that very same day it's like a
flip-flop flip it's a move rarely seen
because it might make voters think the
person doing it is either a unstable be
not a genius or C truly has no idea what
they are saying at any given moment or
downright
is the is the bottom one hey the media
are pushing this narrative now I think
that this narrative is largely unfair
when it comes to policy but Trump cannot
play directly into the teeth of that
narrative and hope to win a victory the
whole goal of politics is to make it
very hard to vote for your opponent and
very easy to vote for you that is the
art of politics it's make it very
difficult to vote for Hillary Clinton
but make it very easy to vote for Donald
Trump maybe you want to knock down all
the obstacles to people voting for you
that doesn't mean being
non-controversial it means being
controversial in very specific ways
picking out the flaws of your opponent
pointing those out making it difficult
for people to get over the hump to vote
for that person but Trump playing into
the teeth of this is a mistake and it's
why Joe Biden continues to lead in the
Democratic primaries Joe Biden put out
an ad in the last 48 hours and it is in
fact a very good ad from Joe Biden
this doesn't mean Joe Biden's good
candidate he is not he is old his
doddering he is unstable he makes
mistakes regularly he's basically half
alive at this point he's cobbled
together like some sort of bizarre
cyborg he he's like the floating head
from Futurama I mean it's it's he's a
terrible terrible candidate but his
entire pitch is look at me I'm boring I
drove Joe Biden is banking on you'd
rather have somebody dead be President
than president Trump it's the weekend at
Bernie's campaign just wheel me around
and staple that toupee to the top of my
head and I'm ready to go man so Joe
Biden's new ad is exactly this remember
the old days when it wasn't this crazy
it can be like that again with Joe Biden
here's his ad ironically entitled bones
which is a bad name for an ad when
you're a thousand years old here's
Biden's ad we know in our bones this
election is different the stakes are
higher the threat more serious we have
to
Donald Trump and all the polls agreed
Joe Biden is the strongest Democrat to
do the job no one is more qualified for
eight years President Obama and Vice
President Biden we're an administration
America could be proud of our allies
could trust and our kids could look up
to together they work to save the
American economy goes on like this right
this is a smart tactic from Joe Biden
he's stapling himself to Obama's pant
leg now most Republicans most
conservatives are looking at this and
going this is a pretty sepia toned image
of the Obama years I'm not seeing a lot
of pictures of Ferguson burning or
Baltimore burning not seeing a lot of
pictures of what happened in Dallas with
police officers not seeing the slowest
recovery in American history not seeing
us basically in open warfare with many
of our key allies including both Britain
as well as Israel not seeing any of that
and not seeing the Iran nuclear deal
anywhere in these ads but this is
Biden's pitch in the media are pushing
that pitch by portraying Trump is
unstable and when Trump when bad Trump
takes precedence over a good Trump
that's a big problem it's the reason why
why Biden is leading it's also the
reason why cory booker is going nowhere
so cory booker is now overtly trying to
make the case that you shouldn't pick
the candidate who's a safe bet he was
bound to fail so here is mr. Potatohead
cory booker he brought out his angry
eyes to talk about why you shouldn't
make Joe Biden the nominee we've never
had someone leading in the polls this
far out that went on to be the president
is base Carter Bill Clinton Barack Obama
all considered underdogs at this point
but you know what they could do they
could speak to the American spirit they
can excite an energized people they can
get crowds on their feet we need a
candidate that is not the safe bet we
need the candidate that can speak not
just to the head but to the heart and to
the gut the heart and the gut oh yeah
yeah me
most men mechanized politician in this
race you need me robot Corey I'm a good
friend imaginary t-bone so yeah that's
not going to work that's not going to
work and you're starting to see some of
the Democrats actually understand this
right senator Bernie Sanders even today
changed out changed how his
medicare-for-all plan would work he's
now trying to appeal to union workers so
that he can overcome Elizabeth Warren's
challenge he announced the key change
was Medicare for all insurance plan on
Wednesday a move meant to assuage fears
on the part of organized labor who
supported me
heatedly sought by all of the candidates
for the Democratic presidential
nomination labor representatives had
told Sanders his medicare-for-all plan
was killing their Cadillac plans
so naturally Bernie is now going to
exempt those plans the change would
effectively give organized labor more
negotiating power than other consumers
who would have under his plans they get
special treatment by forcing employers
to pay out any money they save to union
members and other benefits so in other
words if companies have a union and
taxpayer dollars now cover Medicare for
all the money over and above that that
which they are paying in taxes that
would have gone to the union members and
Cadillac benefits now must be paid
through other forms to the union members
so he's gonna give special goodies to
the union members Democrats are now
starting to make compromises with their
key principles in order to be seen as
the safe choice and what does this
suggest it suggests that President Trump
needs to find a way to avoid being seen
as the bat bleep loony guy out there in
the race because the fact is the
Democrats are the ones who are promoting
an agenda that is crazy I mean their
genders crazy they're promoting an
abortion on demand open borders agenda
they are promoting an agenda that would
slash America's military to the bone
again they are proposing an agenda that
would significantly hamper the growth of
America's economy in the name of a non
negotiated climate deal that would not
effectively lower the possibility of
climate change over the course of the
next century because America is only
responsible about 15 percent of the
world's global carbon emissions
Democrats plans are not workable they're
not workable and this is why I say if
Trump were smart what he would do is
just point at them like Donald
Sutherland an invasion of the body
snatchers he would just stand there and
pointed them that's all he cannot appear
to be the volatile character in this
race because if it's a referendum on
Trump's volatility he's gonna lose if
this is a referendum on democratic
policy which is in and of itself
unstable and volatile then Trump has a
serious shot at victory okay meanwhile
we do have to pay a fond farewell to jay
Inslee breaking news jay Inslee was
running for president of the United
States not anymore
he has dropped out of the 2020
presidential race he's gonna run for
governor of Washington again his
immediate family were the first to know
and also the only people to know because
nobody knew the jay inslee was running
in the first place he just kept showing
up and shouting about climate change
over and over jay Inslee is one of it
one of America's key heroes
we've been up a fond farewell by playing
his theme music do we have that jay
inslee fit by jay Inslee who never
pulled above 1% but I love how the New
York Times covers this governor jay
Inslee of Washington who mounted a
dogged presidential candidacy raised the
alarm about climate change dropped out
of the 2020 race Wednesday after
struggling to earn a place in the next
Democratic primary debate only the New
York Times would describe a campaign
that failed to garner 1 percent approval
rating dogged like I don't remember them
calling Marco Rubio's campaign dogged do
you mr. Inslee plans to compete for a
different office instead he's already
running for a third term as governor in
2020 in Washington State even as Seattle
declines into horror and irrelevance
while his presidential campaign had
advanced the dialogue on climate change
mr. Inslee said he had concluded that
the electoral obstacles before him were
insurmountable Inslee said in an
interview Wednesday night on MSNBC I'm
not going to be the president so I'm
withdrawing tonight from the race to the
great consternation of no one he said
he's not going to endorse any other
Democrat yeah I'm sure that the
Democrats are just clamoring for the jay
Inslee endorse them endorsement
basically he wants to be Secretary of
the Interior the announcement came only
hours after Inslee released the sixth
and final part of a climate plan that
ballooned to about 200 pages can't
imagine why he didn't pick up support
I'm gonna help all the other candidates
raise their level of ambition on this
Inslee said adding we need all of them
to raise their a-game Inslee was 68
years old was there is there like a
Democrat running who's not beta O'Rourke
who is under the age of 93 it said when
well the baby boomers just stopped
running I feel like that would be a good
idea like jay Inslee was the young he
was the young buck in this race he was
the young guy in this race it is
incredible to me that that these these
Democratics these Democratic candidates
are so old it really is amazing it's an
amazing amazing thing and it speaks to a
party that is rapidly running out of
ideas in a very very serious way
meanwhile I do have to make a quick note
here I think that Elizabeth Warren is
multiplying and it's scaring me so yeah
today CNN reported that in Elizabeth
Warren doppelganger showed up to one of
her to one of her events and the picture
is quite frightening I literally do not
know which one of these women is
Elizabeth Warren they look exactly the
same they've the same haircut they have
the same glasses they have the same
outfit it's creepy as all hell here was
CNN reporting meeting her doppelganger
is one thing Elizabeth Warren didn't
have a plan for this is just like being
here with family yeah your twin
Stephanie Oyen has dressed up as
Elizabeth Warren for Halloween so when
she got ready to attend Warren's
Minnesota rally I thought it would just
put on the blazer and go to the rally
and get a couple little giggles but
instead of giggles people just started
turning oh my god it's Warren it's
Warren it was really touching to see the
number of people who had tears in their
eyes they had said things like you're my
hero I felt terrible having to tell them
that well I mean we don't need more than
one like really please we in fact we
don't even need one in the presidential
race please please stop the Elizabeth
Warren spawning problem a stop it's like
spores just multiplying like this this
is this cannot this cannot continue if
all of Iowa becomes Elizabeth Warren's
that you can only stand so many women in
the local HOA meeting scolding you about
painting your front window cell there
are only so many people like that you
can stand in a particular radius and
Elizabeth Warren is every one of those
people is Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth
Warren is the Skjold from your HLA we
can only have so many of those people in
a particular radius before the entire
earth implodes that was that was this is
basically turning into a horror story I
mean this this presidential race I don't
say it's it's it's become it's become
too frightening for me okay time for a
thing I like and then a quick thing that
I hate so thing that I like today so I
just want to talk about the cement that
we had last night it's a daily wire
backstage last night believe it or not
it was really good event I know I was
talking it down I know I sounded
unenthusiastic about being there mainly
because I was but still it was pretty
fun about 3,000 people showed up to hear
Michael Mills jabber nonsensically and
it was it was pretty great now the only
downside was that it ended really late
addenda like 11 o'clock at night and
people were literally falling asleep on
the roads in my security that drove me
said that he spotted two separate
people who had fallen asleep on the road
last night and this reminded me of a
story so it's time for a brief story I
rarely do story time but this reminded
me of the story and I feel like this
story deserves to be told because it
speaks to the in efficacy of California
state government so several years ago I
was driving back from Sacramento to Los
Angeles my wife's family is from the
Sacramento area we're driving back from
Sacramento to Los Angeles
and I was in the car with my wife and my
sister-in-law and my brother-in-law
we're taking their car we're driving
back there is no air conditioning in the
car it is the middle of summer is one
o'clock in the morning and the radio is
broken so I can't even listen music we
get down close to Los Angeles on the i-5
just getting off the grapevine and
suddenly the traffic comes to a dead
halt and I mean a dead stop for an hour
and a half
everybody in the car is asleep really
enjoying themselves I'm sitting behind
the wheel white knuckling it moving six
inches forward every 15 minutes or so
it's really a wonderful wonderful
experience and after about an hour and a
half of this finally the traffic starts
to move again and as we move forward in
the traffic I look to see what is the
crucial piece of work that had to be
done at 1:30 in the morning that
prevented me from getting to sleep until
3:30 and we start moving and I see that
they've blocked off for three of the
four lanes and nothing is happening
there are no machines there are no
people they blocked it off presumably so
that they couldn't check a box and then
tell people they'd been doing work
because no work had been done by this
point I was so frustrated and tired and
angry that I rolled down my window and
as we rolled forward I reached out of
the car and I picked up a traffic cone
and I dumped it in my wife's lap and my
wife wakes up with the giant orange
traffic cone in her lap and she turns to
me and she says what the hell is this
and I said I paid taxes in this state
and I get nothing back except I get to
sit in traffic for an hour and a half
this cone is mine I paid for this cone
that cone sits on our property to this
day we have had that cone for seven
years
we've moved three times in seven years
that cone has always come with me
because that's the only thing I've ever
gotten from the state government of
California apparently so I don't know
why I decided to tell that story but I
hope you enjoyed it as much as I didn't
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
by the way that is I believe my only
criminal alone now I have a very very
bad traffic ticket I've talked about it
on the program before I got caught doing
well over 100 miles an hour had my
license suspended that was my those are
my bad boys bad boy days cruising around
the i-5 in my Honda Civic in any case
quick thing and that I hate so mad
Iglesias the Ralph Wiggum of the
internet had a real take about weddings
the other day now I will admit as a man
I don't care about weddings I really
don't like I would have been fine
marrying my wife civilly and religiously
and doing it in like a small room and
then having like a cake and going home
and watching TV like that I've been fine
but women dream of the big weddings and
so gentlemen in the audience if you're
getting married
stop trying to negotiate with your wife
what the wedding is gonna be like stop
it it's her day it's not your day stop
moaning about it you're being you're
being a pansy stop it okay but I
generally agree with the idea that you
shouldn't spend 75 thousand a hundred
thousand dollars on a wedding I take
that put it on a down payment for a
house spend ten grand on a wedding you
can do something perfectly serviceable
at the local holiday and Express and
it'll be fine okay but Matthew Iglesias
has a different take because again he's
the Ralph Wiggum of the Internet he says
the government should try to do
something the government should try to
do something to discourage expensive
weddings and wedding related activities
which seems to cause a lot of stress in
people's finances and interpersonal
relationships and probably discouraged
people from getting married we'd be way
better off with the norm of cheaper
weddings and the money or repurposed for
family vacations down the road okay
I may agree with that last part and I
may agree that you put the money on a
down payment but I love that Matt
Iglesias his first move always is the
government should do something about it
you know women who want to have nice
weddings the government should jail you
probably I feel like the government
should punish you if you want to spend
money on a nice wedding because the
government knows better than you how you
should get married after all isn't the
government famous for promoting marriage
by completely destroying the institution
over the last 50 years man this is the
problem with so many folks on the Left
they see something and they get angry at
it they're like you know it'd be an
awesome thing if we had a giant group of
people paid for with tax dollars who
could point the gun at somebody and make
them do what I want if you don't think
that this is a sort of fistic
said that the government is supposed to
cram down particular understandings of
how you do weddings I don't know what to
tell you if you want the government
dictating how you ought to do your
wedding man
don't live in America because that is
not what this country was built for all
right we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Stevens audio is mixed by
Mike Caro Mina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant NIC
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you